one of my favorite memories of Dwight
was being in the Detroit Airport and
this really overweight crazy-looking
bedraggled baggage handler comes running
up to me he's like yo boy boy yo yo
and he's like running from a long
distance and he's holding out his phone
and I was like okay he's gonna ask to
take his picture
and he holds up his phone right to my
face and on it it says I can and do cut
my own hair and it says like from Katy
and he goes you don't understand my
daughter and I I don't know why he talks
like this he's from Detroit I don't know
why maybe he was from the Bronx
originally or it's just my
characterization because my daughter and
I we exchanged white texts all day long
it's awesome you're awesome you bring us
together and that's what I think about
is uh is I think that doing comedy and
playing Dwight is a service not to get
grandiose about it but you know I have a
talent for playing oddball characters
and I can make people laugh and that can
help bring families together and people
will really enjoy it and it puts a smile
on their face and I think that's a
really great thing I try to remember
that
yeah it's a it's an interesting
challenge you know we've done 139
episodes at this point or something like
that and you have to remember at the
beginning of each new episode you know
this is fresh this is a this is a this
is you're discovering these moments for
the first time you can't phone it in you
can't clock it in you need to keep
things scintillating and in the moment
really listen and really kind of like
tap back into those instincts of like
what would white do how would white look
at this you have to think as Dwight
see the world through through Dwight's
eyes and it doesn't definitely take a
little focus in concentration to keep
sustaining that